.
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
später Tierarzt zu werden.
Nach einem fünfjährigen Studium
starten sie mit viel Elan
ins Berufsleben.
Aber dann kommt der Alltag.
Der macht viel Freude,
aber auch viele Schwierigkeiten.
Es gibt viele Überraschungen.
Er freut sich so sehr wie Sie.
Wir begleiteten
drei junge Tierärztinnen:
Alix spezialisiert sich momentan
in der Notfallstation des Tierspitals
in Bern in der Spitzentechnologie.
Zusammen mit ihrem Team
hat sie alle kritischen Fälle,
die täglich eingeliefert werden.
Im Kanton Waadt
steht Florence zwischen Rindern
und Pferden des Broye-Gebiets.
Es gibt viel Druck in der Bauernwelt,
aber Florence behält ihre Ruhe
und ihre gute Laune.
Nach ihrer Zeit
mit Kühen und Schafen im Jura
spezialisiert sich Éléonore jetzt
auf Kleintiere in Estavayer-le-Lac.
Hier hat sie
auch oft mit den Besitzern zu tun,
die ihre Tiere extrem gern haben.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärztinnen.
Karina fuhr von Crans-Montana
direkt nach Bern ins Tierspital.
Sie macht sich Sorgen um ihren Hund.
Es ist ein besonderer Hund
und sie liebt ihn sehr.
Sie heisst Diva
und sie ist eine Diva.
Sie ist sehr gesetzt.
Auf Englisch würde man sagen aloof.
Etwas distanziert.
Nicht von mir, aber von allem,
was um sie herum passiert.
Sie ist immer bei mir.
Sie ist magisch.
Wie lange behalten Sie sie?
Ähm ... Das weiss ich nicht.
Karina hat grosse Erwartungen
und will,
dass man sich so schnell wie möglich
um ihre Diva kümmert.
Machen Sie jetzt eine Blutentnahme?
- Nein, nicht einfach so.
Sie kam hierher,
weil das Tierspital Bern
nach den neusten
medizinischen Kenntnissen arbeitet.
Am Dienstag wollte sie nicht mehr
fressen. Das kam noch nie vor.
Dann begann sie zu zittern.
Etwas hat ihr wehgetan.
Karina will schnell alle nötigen
Untersuchungen machen lassen.
Alles dreht sich um sie.
Sie ist mein Leben.
Komm, komm mit mir!
* Sie pfeift. *
Komm!
Am besten tragen Sie sie.
So fühlt sie sich wohl.
Ich mache alles,
damit sie wieder gesund wird.
Ich würde auch
in die Staaten fliegen.
In der Notaufnahme wird Diva
von Alix und ihrer Chefin abgehört.
Es sieht nicht aus,
als hätte Diva Schmerzen.
Der Bauch ist angespannt.
Sie ist auch sehr gestresst.
Jetzt hat sie auch Stress,
weil sie normalerweise
von allen nur verhätschelt wird.
Sie ist ein Teddy Bear Dog.
Eine sehr seltene Rasse, die
die Besitzerin nur in England fand.
Ich nahm
mit der Züchterin Kontakt auf.
Sie hatte
eine dreijährige Warteliste.
Darum wollte ich umso mehr
genau so einen Hund.
Um einen solchen Teddybären
zu bekommen,
musste sich Karina zuerst ausweisen.
Ich schickte der Züchterin
meinen CV.
Ich lebe in Crans-Montana.
Sie war sofort begeistert, dass
einer ihrer Hunde dort leben könnte.
Sie hat mich zuoberst
auf die Liste getan.
Und dann hat sie
gleich vom nächsten Wurf
einen Welpen für mich ausgewählt.
Diva hat bereits
eine dicke Krankenakte.
Alix und Sabrina entdecken darin ein
ausgetüfteltes Ernährungsprogramm.
Home Cooked Diet.
Was hat sie?
Da, schau: Home Cooked Diet.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Es steht hier nur ...
Wenn, dann da hinten. Da!
Seit Juli.
Alix ist beruhigt: Diva ist stabil.
Es ist noch kein Notfall.
Natürlich hat Alix bereits
eine spezielle Beziehung zu Diva.
Komm, Diva, hopp, hopp!
Sie wartet auf dich.
Jetzt muss Alix
mit der Besitzerin besprechen,
welche Untersuchungen
sie machen will.
Auf Englisch, aber das
bringt Alix nicht aus dem Konzept.
Wollen Sie lieber Englisch sprechen?
Wie Sie wollen.
Englisch geht auch, aber
Schweizerdeutsch wäre einfacher.
Sie nehmen Blut ...
Das Blut, die Lunge röntgen,
einen Bauchultraschall
und zytologische Tests.
Das einzige Problem: Sie ist
momentan etwas dehydriert ist.
Ich weiss, dass Sie sie
nicht bei uns lassen wollen,
aber es wäre für sie besser.
Der Hund ist dehydriert.
Er braucht eine Infusion und das
kann sie nicht daheim machen.
Alix
muss die Besitzerin dazu bringen,
den Hund über Nacht
im Spital zu lassen.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Und wenn ich hier
mit dem Hund ins Hotel gehe
und am Morgen wieder mit ihm komme?
Nein, leider nicht.
Wir können sie nicht noch einmal auf
der Notfallstation neu anmelden.
Das ist ein interner Transfer.
Geben Sie ihr
für die Nacht ein Beruhigungsmittel?
Nein, es ist ihr total wohl bei mir.
Ich hielt sie im Arm
und sie lehnte den Kopf an mich.
Ah, gekuschelt.
- Ja, ja.
Sie ist ein richtiger Schatz,
so herzig.
Alix möchte der Besitzerin
versichern, dass alles gut ist.
Wir kochen hier Poulet und haben
daneben eine grosse Auswahl an ...
Wer kocht?
- Unsere Assistenten kochen.
Ist es Bio-Poulet?
- Das weiss ich leider nicht.
Aber das Fleisch, das die
Assistenten in der Küche zubereiten,
ist frisch.
Karina lässt ihren Hund erst hier,
wenn alles geklärt ist.
Alix nimmt sich Zeit,
um ihr Vertrauen zu gewinnen.
Also, ich gebe Ihnen freie Hand.
Egal was es kostet, so lange ...
Nein, es geht nicht ums Geld,
es geht um die Liebe.
Vielen Dank.
Hey, hey!
Das ist übrigens ein Teddy Bear Dog.
Ja, ich habe es gesehen.
Darum hast du
auch ein so schönes Fell,
bist so eine Liebe.
Sie spürt meinen Stress.
Es ist normal, dass man sich Sorgen
macht, wenn man jemanden liebt.
Nicht wahr? Was meinst du?
Wir geben uns Mühe,
dass es schnell geht.
Ich mache mir keine Sorgen,
so lange die Resultate ...
Doch ich mache mir einen Kopf,
aber ich denke
nicht gleich ans Schlimmste.
Ja.
- Wer nimmt sie?- Meine Kollegin.
Ich komme
noch mit Ihnen zum Empfang.
Gut, Schätzchen!
Wir schauen, dass alles gut geht.
Du musst dir keine Sorgen machen.
Ich kam mit meinem Hund und
habe vor, wieder mit ihr zu gehen -
lebendig.
Hoffentlich.
Im Wartesaal der Tierpraxis
in Estavayer-le-Lac versucht Viviane,
ihren vierjährigen Beagle
aus der Ecke zu ziehen.
Komm, komm Jessie, komm!
Etwas am Gesäss
muss Jessie extrem stören.
Als ich ihr heute um 7 Uhr
zu Fressen gab,
schleifte sie
das Gesäss am Boden nach.
Das fand ich eigenartig.
Als wir aus dem Haus wollten,
sah ich einen Blutflecken am Boden.
Ich fragte mich, ob Hunde
auch Hämorriden haben können.
19 1/2?
- Ja.
Jessie will ihr Gesäss
einfach nicht hochheben.
Ihre Besitzerin ist es nicht gewohnt,
sie zu tragen.
Normalerweise
ist der Hund sehr lebhaft.
Es ist ein Beagle. Wir bekamen ihn
von seiner vorherigen Besitzerin,
die Multiple Sklerose bekam.
Der Hund wurde ihr
zu lebhaft und zu stark.
Heute ist er
der Liebling der Familie.
Ich habe drei
mittlerweile erwachsene Kinder
und das ist ein Nachzügler.
Ihr tut das Gesäss weh?
- Ja, genau.
Hat sie schon einmal das Gesäss
auf dem Boden nachgeschleift?
Heute Morgen.
Als ich den Schwanz hochhielt, sah
ich, dass der Hund Schmerzen hat.
Die rechte Analdrüse blutete
und ich sah ein Loch,
wo keines sein sollte.
Also, eine der beiden Analdrüsen
ist verstopft.
Ähm, ich denke, sie ist geplatzt.
Hier ist ein Loch.
Die Analdrüsen sind kleine Beutel
auf beiden Seiten des Afters.
Darin hat es ein Sekret,
das sehr stinkt.
So markieren Hunde Reviere.
Normalerweise werden diese Beutel
beim Absetzten des Kots
alleine geleert.
Wenn nun ein Hund Verdauungspro-
bleme hat oder der Kot zu weich ist,
werden die Analbeutel
nicht richtig geleert.
Dann sind sie verstopft
oder sogar entzündet.
Die entzündete Analdrüse
muss Eléonore nun ausspülen.
Wir müssen die Beutel ausspülen.
Wir müssen sie sedieren,
weil das sehr schmerzhaft ist.
Das wäre das Beste.
- Oh, Schatz.
Sie lief sehr tapfer,
wie wenn nichts wäre - ganz normal.
Ein Kämpfer - die Beagle.
Ja, die Beagle sind sehr belastbar.
Oh, gut haben wir das jetzt bemerkt.
Hätte ich etwas tun können,
um das zu verhindern?
Das Problem ist,
dass sie Ihnen nichts sagen kann.
Bis jetzt hat sie
die Schmerzen ertragen,
aber der geplatzte Analbeutel
hat sie zu sehr geschmerzt.
Das tut sehr weh.
Ich glaube, sie macht sich Vorwürfe,
aber das muss sie nicht.
Ihr Hund wollte die Schmerzen
so lang wie möglich verstecken.
Dann hat er es
nicht mehr ausgehalten.
Wir betäuben sie,
so lange Sie dabei sind.
Nachher spülen wir den Abszess aus.
Viviane wird es zusehends ungeheuer.
Und dann noch mit Propofol.
Das hat doch
Michael Jackson genommen.- Genau.
Die Besitzerin hat das Propofol
mit Michael Jacksons Tod
in Verbindung gebracht.
Ich habe sie beruhigt. Wir brauchen
das Mittel oft für kurze Narkosen.
Damit erwacht der Hund
nach 20 Min. wieder.
Darum nehmen wir meistens das,
wenn es um kurze Eingriffe geht.
Ich glaube,
ich kann das nicht sehen.
Wenn Sie kein Blut sehen können,
gehen Sie besser raus.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich hierbleiben kann.
Dann gehen Sie besser raus.
- Ich nehme sie.
Schläft sie schnell ein?
- Sehr schnell.
Das erinnert mich
zu stark an Sprite.
Der letzte sehr geliebte Hund,
den wir hatten ...
Ja ...
Es ist so schmerzhaft,
wenn man spürt, dass er geht.
Das wollte ich
auf keinen Fall noch einmal erleben.
Sicher?
- Sicher. Alles ist gut.
Der Eingriff dauert 10 Min.,
trotzdem lässt Viviane
ihren Hund nur ungern zurück.
Ich hoffe, es geht alles gut und es
gibt keine Infektionen und äh ...
Und es ist auch nichts Schlimmeres
als sie gesagt hat.
Ein Eingriff ist immer riskant.
Aber kaum ist Viviane weg ...
Sie springt mich gleich an.
- Willst du sie loslassen?
Als die Halterin weg war,
geriet Jessie in Panik.
Wir konnten sie kaum halten.
Sie suchte ihr Frauchen.
Nachher war es so,
dass sie sie nicht gefunden hat.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Ganz ruhig!
Eléonore macht Plan B:
Eine Spritze in den Muskel.
Ganz ruhig! Bald geht es dir besser.
Ich lass dich runter.
Ja, jetzt bist du frei.
Das geht besser und man muss
den Hund nicht so lange halten.
Am Ende wirkt es gleich,
aber es geht etwas länger.
Eine Viertelstunde
später schläft Jessie tief.
Jetzt kommt sie ins Operationszimmer,
in dem Eléonore
den offenen Analbeutel säubern kann.
Im Normalfall hat eine Analdrüse ein
kleines Loch das die Drüse entleert.
Sie liegt unter der Haut,
neben dem After.
Hier sieht man das Loch.
Wir müssen es ausspülen,
damit es sich wieder schliesst.
So etwas ist eigentlich
keine grosse Sache.
Dem Hund tut das aber sehr weh,
und wenn man nichts macht,
könnte es eine Infektion geben
und schlimm werden.
Beginnen wir!
Voilà!
Ja, ja, siehst du, es kommt heraus!
Das ist recht viel.
Eléonore und ihre Assistentin
nehmen allen Mut zusammen,
um die beiden Analdrüsen zu entleeren
und zu desinfizieren.
Aber der Gestank
ist fast nicht auszuhalten.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall
angenehmere Eingriffe.
Das ist noch recht heikel.
Im Wachzustand
könnte man so etwas nicht machen.
Die Operation dauerte knapp 10 Min.
Jetzt geht es ca. 1 Std. bis Jessie
langsam aus der Narkose erwacht.
Hey, du bist ja schon aufgesessen.
Das ist ja super.
Hey, du! Leinen wir noch schnell an.
Nicht ziehen!
Noch die letzten Empfehlungen
der Tierärztin.
Wenn sie Durchfall oder etwas
weichen Kot hat, muss man aufpassen.
Dann gebe ich ihr
weniger zu Fressen.
Das mache ich und schaue,
wie es geht.
Jessie ist wie ein Familienmitglied,
darum passe ich jetzt noch mehr auf.
Sobald mir etwas auffällt,
schauen wir weiter.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Danke.
Jetzt ist sie beleidigt, wegen mir.
Ich bin die Böse.
Etwas passt Jessie gar nicht.
Bist du eingeschnappt?
Dass man sie einfach so hinausstellt,
gefällt ihr offensichtlich nicht.
Bist du etwas eingeschnappt?
Aber kaum sind sie draussen,
ist Jessie wieder fröhlich.
Ihr Gesäss wird Viviane
in Zukunft im Auge behalten,
damit es keinen Rückfall gibt.
Florence muss heute Morgen
sofort zu Pierre-Yves
in Russy im Kanton Fribourg.
Seiner Kuh Djamila
geht es gar nicht gut.
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo.
Pierre-Yves lächelt zwar,
aber er ist sehr beunruhigt.
Also, was ist mit ihr los?- Heute
Morgen wollte sie nicht fressen.
Und sie gab wenig Milch.
- Ja.
Wann hat sie gekalbt?
Wenn Florence extra hierherkommt,
hat das einen Grund.
Die Kuh hat
vor zwei oder drei Wochen gekalbert.
Und jetzt
hat der Besitzer angerufen,
weil die Kuh nicht mehr frisst.
Eine Kuh, die gekalbert hat
und nicht frisst,
ist für Florence ein Alarmzeichen.
Denn dahinter könnten
ernste Komplikationen stecken.
Beim Abklopfen hörte es sich
auf der linken Seite an,
wie wenn es Luft im Bauch hat.
Das könnte bedeuten, dass der
Labmagen nach links gerutscht ist.
Der Labmagen
ist einer der vier Kuhmägen.
Florence hört ihn auf der linken
Seite, dabei sollte er rechts liegen.
Sie hört die andere Seite ab
und hört nichts.
D.h., das Magenteil
ist nach rechts gerutscht
und füllt sich mit Gas,
weil die Verdauung blockiert ist.
Die Kuh wird immer weniger fressen
und irgendwann ganz damit aufhören.
So gibt sie auch weniger Milch
und kann sterben.
Es gibt nur eine Lösung: operieren.
Aber das kostet.
Pierre-Yves steht vor der
Entscheidung: Operation oder Metzger.
Es ist eine gute Kuh. Sie hat erst
vor zwei Wochen gekalbert.
Wir müssten sie töten,
wenn sie nicht operiert wird.
Ich finde es schade, sie zu töten.
Ich binde sie hier an.
Solche Operationen werden normaler-
weise im Tierspital durchgeführt.
Aber Florence will keine Zeit
verlieren, man muss sofort operieren.
Im Stall und mit den Mitteln,
die sie hat.
Hast du den Schlauch hier?- Nein.
- Um die Luft abzulassen.
Ah, von der Melkmaschine.
- Ja.- Ich habe ihn.
Mit dem Schlauch der Melkmaschine
wird die Luft aus dem Magen gelassen.
Du kannst ihn schon anschliessen.
Wenn wir soweit sind,
drehst du den Hahn auf.
Zusammen mit zwei Kolleginnen
verwandelte Florence den Stall
in einen provisorischen OP-Saal.
Sie bereitet sich
auf eine schwierige Operation vor.
Es ist ein grosser Eingriff
mit vielen möglichen Komplikationen.
Es könnte innere Blutungen geben
oder nachher Infektionen.
Die Kuh könnte sich
während dem Eingriff hinlegen ...
Es könnte alles passieren.
Also, du musst den Schwanz
in die Höhe halten.- Ja.
Im Gegensatz zum Tierspital
wird hier im Stall operiert.
Das ist gar nicht einfach.
Oh! Oh, oh, oh!
Als Erstes gibt es ein Lokalnarkose.
Und schon hier
muss Florence aufpassen.
Hey!
- Langsam!
Es kam schon vor, dass eine Kuh
während der Operation
ausgeschlagen hat.
Das macht die Situation
natürlich nicht einfacher,
weil man sehr genau arbeiten muss.
Wenn man ständig Angst hat,
getreten zu werden,
dann ist man weniger konzentriert.
Nach ein paar Minuten prüft Florence,
ob die Narkose wirkt.
Sie ist hartnäckig.
Gut, dann wird eben sediert.
Die Lokalnarkose wirkt zu wenig,
darum gibt es nun
ein Beruhigungsmittel.
Damit riskiert Florence aber,
dass die Kuh
während der Operation einschläft.
Wenn sich sich hinlegt, müsste sie
auf die richtige Seite liegen,
mit der Öffnung nach oben.
Sie darf nicht auf die rechte Seite
liegen,
denn während der Operation
liegt der Darm draussen.
Wird der Darm schmutzig, gibt das
eine Infektion im Bauchraum.
Das könnte man nicht vermeiden -
und die Kuh wäre verloren.
Pierre-Yves ist unruhig.
Er muss gut aufpassen.
Alles ist parat.
So.
Also, beginnen wir.
Du kannst den Schwanz hochhalten.
- Okay.
Jetzt kommt der Einschnitt, auch das
ist ein gefährlicher Schritt.
Beim Einschnitt
riskiert man immer eine Blutung,
weil man sehr nahe
an die grossen Blutgefässe kommt.
Darum muss man genau schauen,
was man macht
und keinen falschen Schnitt machen.
Jetzt ist sie drin
und tastet die Organe ab.
Auch das ist eine sehr heikle Phase.
Also, zuerst kommt der Panzen.
Und daneben spüre ich
einen riesigen Ballon.
Den riesigen Ballon,
der ein Teil des Magens ist,
sticht Florence
nun mit einer Nadel auf.
Also jetzt darfst du
ja nicht ausschlagen, gell.
Jetzt bin ich im Labmagen.
Oh, oh! Ah, jetzt ist es gut!
Jetzt kommt der Schlauch
der Melkmaschine zum Einsatz -
um die Luft abzusaugen.
* Sauggeräusch *
Funktioniert es?- Nein, bis jetzt
saugt es keine Luft an.
So etwas geht immer lange,
weil sich im Labmagen
viel Luft ansammeln kann.
Ich stach mit einer Nadel hinein,
damit wir die Luft
über einen Schlauch ablassen können.
Aber wir hatten
ein Problem mit zwei Schläuchen.
Die Luft ging nicht gut weg.
Aber Pierre-Yves
hat den Schaden schnell behoben.
Funktioniert es?
- Ja, es schrumpft ein wenig.
Jetzt sollte es besser gehen.
Ja, jetzt geht es,
aber mich schmerzt mein Arm.
Ich bin viel zu klein für diese Kuh.
Ich komme fast nicht hin.
Aber jetzt bin ich dran.
Ich glaube, die Luft ist draussen.
Es ist gut.
- Bist du fertig?
Du kannst abstellen, es reicht.
Die Operation ist noch nicht fertig.
Den Labmagen
muss sie rechts platzieren.
Zuerst muss man das wieder
am Ausgang des Labmagens fixieren,
und dann den Punkt finden,
wo er hingehört.
Ein Erinnerungsfoto für Pierre-Yves.
Eine Kuh, der der Darm heraushängt,
hat er noch nie gesehen.
Sie zieht alles hinaus
und die Kuh bewegt sich nicht.
Das finde ich sehr eindrücklich.
Die Zeit vergeht und der Eingriff,
geht länger als geplant.
Nicht hinlegen! Jetzt könnte es
sein, dass sie sich hinlegt.
Djamila schwankt. Die Operation
dauert nun schon über 30 Min.
Es wäre eine Katastrophe,
wenn sie sich jetzt hinlegen würde.
Der Magen ist noch offen.
Es eilt.
Florence muss noch den Labmagen
fixieren und die Wunde zunähen.
Voilà, super!
Schön ist die Narbe.
Wow!
Djamila hat bis am Schluss hinge-
halten. Florence ist erleichtert.
Ja, sie ist gut erwacht.
Jetzt hoffen wir, dass sie frisst.
Und das macht sie
schon nach ein paar Minuten.
Vor ein paar Minuten
war sie noch unter dem Messer
und jetzt frisst sie!
Das ist Eindrücklich.
Wenn alles gut geht,
merkt man in einer Woche nicht mehr,
dass sie krank war.
Die Operation ist gelungen -
Florence freut es.
Möchtest du noch etwas trinken?
- Nein danke, es ist gut.
Ich mache noch alles sauber,
und dann muss ich weiter.
Also, einen schönen Abend.
- Dir auch, tschüss!
Djamila geht es schon viel besser,
aber Florence
hat noch nicht Feierabend.
Schon kommt das nächste Telefon.
Es geht um eine Kuh, das ihr Kälbchen
nicht alleine auf die Welt bringt.
Okay, perfekt. Also, bis später.
Und schon fährt die Tierärztin
zum nächsten Patienten.
Im Tierspital in Bern
ist es Zeit für eine Mittagspause.
Es ist fast 14 Uhr und Alix
hat immer noch nichts gegessen.
Sie hat bis jetzt einen Notfall
nach dem anderen betreut.
Irgendwann muss man Pause machen,
auch wenn es nur 10 Min. sind.
Sie kam noch nicht dazu,
ihr Mittagessen zuzubereiten.
Schon klingelt es wieder.
Dann ist es am Empfang.
Zur Sicherheit
schaut Alix kurz nach,
wie dringend
der nächste Notfall ist.
Es sieht nicht schlimm aus,
und die Besitzerin des Hundes
ist sehr verständnisvoll.
Ich habe Zeit.
Ich kann schon warten.
Das ist nett. Vielen Dank.
Endlich kann Alix
ein kleines Mittagessen machen.
Auch Notfälle
muss man richtig einordnen.
Kommt der Notfallarzt
nicht zum Essen, ist das schlimmer,
als wenn das Hündchen
etwas warten muss.
Es ist nicht so schlimm.
Er wirkt recht stabil.
In den 10 Min. in denen ich esse,
passiert schon nichts.
Man muss einfach
gewisse Prioritäten setzen.
Während des Essens studiert sie
die Termine des Nachmittags.
Nach der Mittagspause bringt sie Diva
zum Ultraschalluntersuch.
Die Besitzerin hat eingewilligt, den
Hund für 24 Std. im Spital zu lassen.
Seine Gesundheit macht ihr Angst.
Also, hopp!
Voilà, voilà, voilà, voilà!
Alix macht eine Ultraschall-
untersuchung der Leber und der Milz.
Dafür muss leider
etwas von dem schönen Fell weg.
Kanntest du die Rasse Teddy Bear?
- Nein.
Es ist eine englische Rasse.
Eine Kreuzung zwischen einem Pudel,
einem Shih-Tzu
und einem Schosshündchen.
Okay.
In dem Fall von allem etwas.
- Ja.
Und das ist eine Rasse?
Ja.- Interessant.
- Auf Wikipedia.- Ah, okay.
Aber während der Untersuchung
vergeht Alix das Lächeln.
Die Struktur der Milz
ist sehr unregelmässig.
Man sieht ...
... Gewebeveränderungen.
Das ist kein gutes Zeichen.
- Nein.
Und das ist die Leber.
Auf dem Ultraschallbild
haben wir mehrere Knoten
und Strukturveränderungen
auf der Leber und der Milz gesehen.
Das ist keine gute Nachricht.
Das war von Anfang an klar.
Es gibt narbige
und entzündliche Masse,
aber normalerweise
handelt es sich um eine Masse.
Hier hat es aber gleich mehrere
und erst noch auf mehreren Organen,
nämlich auf der Leber und der Milz.
Was das heisst ist klar:
Der Hund hat Krebs.
Die Chefin der Ultraschallabteilung
kommt.
Sie kann sagen, ob man die Krebsmasse
chirurgisch entfernen kann.
Wie man hier sieht, kann man sagen,
dass die ganze Leber befallen ist.
Das ist sehr schlecht.
Also, nach dem Ultraschall
kann ich sagen,
ein chirurgischer Eingriff ist nicht
möglich, es ist gar nicht möglich,
wenn ich das jetzt so anschaue.
In gewissen Fällen
kann man operieren,
wenn nur ein Organ befallen ist.
Die Milz
ist kein lebenswichtiges Organ,
darum kann man die Milz
bei einem Tier gut entfernen.
Man kann eine Niere entfernen,
vorausgesetzt,
die andere funktioniert gut.
Man kann auch
einen Teil der Leber entfernen.
Das macht man, wenn es nötig ist.
Aber die ganze Leber entfernen,
das geht nicht.
Ohne Leber kann man nicht leben.
Krebs in fortgeschrittenem Stadium,
der nicht mehr operiert werden kann.
Schlimmer
könnte es für Diva nicht sein.
Jetzt muss Alix Karina anrufen und
ihr die traurige Mitteilung machen.
Dabei kommt Alix zugute,
was sie einmal gelernt hat.
Es gibt drei Techniken, um eine
schlimme Nachricht zu überbringen:
Man sagt in den ersten 30 Sek.,
was los ist.
Man sagt es nach 1 1/2 Min.,
oder man redet um den heissen Brei
herum und sagt es erst am Schluss.
Ja ...
Ich sage es meistens sofort.
Das ist Theorie.
In der Praxis sieht es anders aus.
Hier spricht Babarino
vom Tierspital Bern.
Ich habe keine gute Neuigkeiten.
Es ist leider so, dass wir
kranke Gewebemasse gefunden haben
und zwar im Bauchraum.
- Wo genau?
Im Bauchraum.
Es sind leider
schon mehrere Organe befallen.
Alix erklärt Karina,
dass der Fall hoffnungslos ist,
und dass man nichts mehr machen kann.
Karina ist völlig schockiert.
Man merkt es ihr auch an.
Okay, d.h. ich hole sie
heute Abend nicht ab?
Es wäre besser,
sie könnte hierbleiben,
damit wir ihr
die nötige Pflege geben können:
Flüssigkeit und Medikamente, um zu
schauen, ob es ihr so besser geht.
Gut, streicheln Sie sie
bitte für mich.
Das mache ich sicher.
Sie war sehr lieb.
Ich war vorher bei ihr.
Sie lag in ihrem Korb
und ich brachte sie in ihre Box.
Wir gaben ihr Ihren Pullover,
so hat sie etwas von Ihnen.
Wir schauen gut,
dass es ihr an nichts fehlt.
Wir gehen bis zum Maximum.
Gut.
Also, danke.- Bitte.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Kraft.
Auf Wiederhören.
* Schluchzen *
Ich habe das Gefühle,
sie hat es erwartet.
Darum kam sie auch
auf die Notfallstation,
obwohl es ihrem Hund
nicht so schlecht ging.
Jetzt muss sie das alles
zuerst einmal verkraften.
Das waren
viele unschöne Informationen.
Das wird kein schöner Abend für sie.
Ja oje.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Heute ist ein besonderer Tag
für Eléonore.
Sie hat fei, ist aber trotzdem
schon früh unterwegs.
Sie hat ein wichtiges Rendezvous.
Salut, Maman!
Sie trifft ihre Eltern
und ihren Bruder.
Hoi, Kleine!
- Wie geht's?
Gut, und dir?
- Mir auch.
Hallo, Bruder!
- Hoi!
Grüezi!
- Grüezi!
Die ganze Familie kommt zusammen,
um Eléonore bei diesem
wichtigen Schritt zu begleiten.
Kommt mit in den Garten.
* Bellen *
Bei der Züchterin Rosalie
wählt Eléonore heute
ein Hündchen für sich aus.
Das erste eigene Haustier
für unsere Tierärztin,
die in der Stadt aufgewachsen ist.
Rosalie gibt ihr
zwei Welpen zur Auswahl.
Das ist Ostralie.
Hoppla!
Sie können sie halten.
Voilà!
Das ist Omega. Er ist
ein Monat und zwei Wochen alt.
Dieser hier.
- Oh, so süss.
Ja, hallo!
Ich wollte schon immer einen Hund.
Es ist mein Kindertraum.
Aber ich musste waren,
bis alles stimmt.
Oh, ich kann mich nicht entscheiden.
Das Hündchen ist ein Geschenk
von Gaëtane, Eléonores Mutter.
Ich habe es ihr
vor Ewigkeiten versprochen.
Seit dem Diplom.
- Ja, genau.
Dass sie einen Hund haben kann.
Jetzt stimmt alles.
Sie wohnt nicht mehr in der Stadt
und hat eine geräumige Wohnung.
Sie kann den Hund
auch zur Arbeit mitnehmen.
Eléonore hat eine originelle Rasse
ausgewählt: einen Corgi.
Die Züchterin ist damit
natürlich sehr einverstanden.
Es sind aussergewöhnliche Hunde.
Nicht einfach ein Hund - ein Corgi.
Diese Hunde finde ich super.
Sie sind sehr klein,
haben eine spezielle Schnauze
und man sieht sie
auf der Strasse nicht oft.
Ich kannte sie. Das sind
klassische, englische Hunde.
Die Queen hat immer
ein paar davon um sich herum.
(Züchterin)Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass Ostralie
gut zu Ihrem Lebensstil passt.
Wenn Sie sie immer mitnehmen wollen,
ist das der richtige Hund.
Oh, das Schätzchen!
Eléonore lässt sich überzeugen
und wählt Ostralie.
Die ganze Familie freut sich.
Alle haben Ostralie
sofort in ihr Herz geschlossen.
Noch ein Abschiedsküsschen
von der Züchterin ...
Tschüss!
... und schon fährt Ostralie
ihrem neuen Leben entgegen.
Tschau!
Das nächste Mal kommst du
in Begleitung.- Ja.
Tschau, Kleine!
Bis bald!
Es hat mich sehr gefreut,
dass meine Eltern dabei waren.
Ich fragte sie, ob sie kommen.
Das war ein sehr wichtiger Schritt
in meinem Leben,
darum wollte ich,
dass sie dabei sind.
Danke, dass ihr gekommen seid.
- Aber das ist doch klar.
Komm gut nach Hause!
Nach der kurzen Pause
beginnt morgen wieder der Alltag.
In Corcelles in der Waadt besuchen
wir einen Hof mit rund 30 Milchkühen.
Kaethlin ist erst 25 und führt
den Hof mit ihrem Bruder Lionel,
seit ihr Vater verletzt ist.
* Muhen *
Heute haben sie
ein Problem mit Clarinette.
Als sie heute Morgen
in den Melkstand kam, sah ich,
dass sie etwas lahmt.
In der Box
hat sie ihren Fuss kaum abgestellt.
Er war geschwollen.
Kaethlin schaut gut zu ihren Kühen
und hat sofort gemerkt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Es ist wie bei den Menschen.
Ist eine Freundin grantig,
weiss man, dass etwas los ist.
Kaethlin fand, sie benachrichtige
lieber den Tierarzt.
Clarinette
ist eine ihrer besten Milchkühe.
Sie sollte so schnell wie möglich
wieder auf die Beine kommen.
Als ich es sah,
habe ich sofort angerufen.
Ich fragte sie zuerst, ob sie die
Klauensohle schon angeschaut habe.
Das hat sie noch nicht gemacht.
Darum wollte ich die Kuh
in den Klauenstand stellen,
um die Sohle zu untersuchen.
Der Klauenstand ist ein Gerüst,
in dem die Kühe ruhiggestellt werden,
damit man in Ruhe
an der Klaue arbeiten kann.
Das Pedicure-Set ist parat.
Jetzt muss die Kuh
nur noch in den Klauenstand.
Aber Clarinette denkt nicht daran,
dort hineinzustehen
und macht es unseren jungen Bauern
ziemlich schwer.
Ah!
Sie hatte wirklich
überhaupt keine Lust.
Eigentlich kann man sie gut führen,
aber heute ging gar nichts mehr.
Mal schauen ...
Hopp!
Hey!
Auch sie kommt nicht weiter.
Zehn Leute würden es nicht schaffen.
Sie hätten nicht Kraft genug.
Kaethlin
hat einen anderen Vorschlag.
Man könnte Clarinettes Bein
an der Stange des Geheges anbinden.
Wir können es versuchen,
wenn es anders nicht geht.
Florence findet diese Lösung
nicht so gut,
aber sie hat es eilig.
Es ist nervig, ich hätte die Klauen
gerne genau angeschaut.
Aber dafür
muss die Kuh im Klauenstand sein,
sonst ist man nicht sicher.
Aber sie wollte
einfach nicht hinein.
Lahmt sie stark?
Heute Morgen hat sie den Fuss
kaum mehr abgestellt.
Florence muss die Klaue
unbedingt aus der Nähe anschauen.
Eine gefährliche Geschichte.
Sie macht, was sie will, auch
zu dritt schaffen wir es nicht.
Ich auf jeden Fall nicht.
Mit meinen 60 kg kann ich unmöglich
eine Kuh hochheben.
Sie versuchen es noch einmal.
Und sie schlägt wieder aus.
Florence lässt es sein.
Nein, es hat keinen Sinn.
Wir lassen es sein.
Sonst macht sie sich noch mehr weh.
Achtung!
Florence muss die Klaue in dieser
gefährlichen Position untersuchen.
Mit einem Tritt
kann die Kuh sie spitalreif treten.
Man ist überhaupt nicht ruhig.
Die Kuh war sehr aufgeregt
und wollte nicht stillhalten.
Sie hat ständig ausgeschlagen
und hat mich auch fast getroffen.
Man muss sehr aufpassen.
Ho, hör endlich auf!
- Man muss vorsichtig sein.
Ein Tritt einer Kuh
kann einem nach hinten werfen
und man kann auf den Kopf fallen.
Das könnte dann schlimm sein.
Florence muss unbedingt
die Sohle der Klaue anschauen,
aber sie traut der Sache nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Und dann versucht es Kathelin noch
einmal, dieses Mal sehr vorsichtig.
Sie müssen schnell machen.
Ich habe auf die Hornschicht an
der Sohle gedrückt, um zu schauen,
ob sie
an einem bestimmten Punkt reagiert.
Das hätte gezeigt, dass dort eine
Infektion, also ein Abszess ist.
Dort ist die Sohle abgenutzt,
nicht wahr?
Ja, das ist die Ferse. Das ist
normal. Deswegen lahmt sie nicht.
Es ist kein Abszess.
Das ist schon einmal gut.
Das spürt sie nicht,
also kein Problem hier.
Florence möchte trotzdem
zwei Therapien verschreiben.
Ich gebe ihr jetzt zwei Spritzen,
eine mit einem entzündungshemmenden
Mittel und eine mit Antibiotika.
Also, ich wollte v.a. vermeiden,
dass man der Kuh
unnötig Antibiotika geben muss.
Wir können es nur mit dem ent-
zündungshemmenden Mittel probieren.
Ist es wegen der Milch?
- Ja, sie gibt besonders viel Milch.
Sie ist eine sehr gute Milchkuh und
gibt zwischen 40 und 50 l Milch.
Die Molkerei
nimmt keine Milch mit Antibiotika.
Solche Milch nehmen sie nicht an.
Jeden Abend nehmen sie Proben.
Hat es Antibiotika drin,
gibt es eine Busse.
Und man muss alle Käse bezahlen,
die damit gemacht wurden.
Wir versuchen es zwei Tage lang.
Wird es nicht besser, muss ich
Antibiotika geben.- Das wäre gut.
Weil sie kein Fieber hat,
können wir es versuchen.
Wenn sie nicht aufhört zu hinken,
muss ich etwas tun.- Ja.
Reichen wohl die Medikamente,
damit Clarinette wieder gesund wird?
Kaethlin will es versuchen.
So, es ist drin. Es ist vorbei.
Das sollte die Entzündung hemmen.
Kaethlin nimmt sich fest vor, ihre
Kuh ohne Antibiotika durchzubringen.
Sie hat klare Ideen, die
die Veterinärin respektieren muss.
Das sind die Medikamente.
Ja, danke.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Danke, ade!
Zum Schluss hat es sich gelohnt.
Clarinette wurde ohne Antibiotika und
ohne einen Tropfen Milch zu vergeuden
wieder gesund.
Gestern hat Alix
im Tierspital in Bern
einen schlimmen Krebs diagnostiziert.
Davon betroffen
ist Karinas Hund Diva.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Wie geht es Ihnen? Konnten sie
schlafen?- Ich habe etwas genommen.
Grüezi!
- Grüezi!
Ein leichtes Schlafmittel.
- Okay.
Im Sprechzimmer
erkläre ich Ihnen alles.
Heute kommt sie mit ihrer Freundin
Christine, die Divas Erzieherin ist.
Ich bekam aus der Zytologie
einen Teil der Resultate.
Andere Werte
müssen sie noch genauer analysieren.
Für den Moment ...
Für Diva kann man nichts mehr machen.
Bei dieser Krebsart
kann es vorkommen,
dass die Gewebsmassen aufgehen,
dann gibt es eine innere Blutung.
Ich gebe Ihnen
eine Liste der Symptome,
auf die man sehr gut achten muss:
Wenn der Hund plötzlich sehr müde
ist, das Herz heftig schlägt
und er zu hecheln beginnt.
Wenn die Lefzen hier oben
ganz weiss werden.
Bei diesen Anzeichen
sollte man sofort zum Tierarzt.
Man muss wissen, dass dann ...
Dann ist es fertig.- Ja.
Im Vergleich zu gestern
geht es Diva heute viel besser.
Gestern war sie gestresst,
weil sie den Ort nicht kannte.
Jetzt kennt sie uns etwas.
Als ich sie heute Morgen unter-
suchte, schwänzelte sie aufgeregt.
Sie sprang mir sogar in den Arm.
Sie ist also wieder fitter,
darum ist es wichtig,
dass Sie den Moment
wirklich geniessen.
Wir werden es sehen.
Hauptsache, sie hat keine Schmerzen.
Schau!
- Diveli!- Schau wer hier ist!
Hey, Baby.
Oh, ja, wer ist denn da?
Ja, jetzt bist du froh, nicht wahr?
So ist es gut.
Hat sie erbrochen?
- Nein.
Ich glaube,
sie hat schlecht geschlafen.
Ihr Nachbar war ziemlich laut.
Darum hat sie wahrscheinlich
eine unruhige Nacht hinter sich.
Sie hat nichts gegessen, oder?
Nein, sie hat
unser Poulet ignoriert.
Wir geben ihr unser Poulet.
Vielen Dank. Ade.
- Danke.- Ade.
Karina und Diva
fahren nach Crans-Montana zurück.
Alles, was Alix
für sie machen konnte,
war der Krankheit
einen Namen zu geben.
Diva hat keine Schmerzen, man kann
sie aber auch nicht behandeln.
Niemand weiss,
wie viel Zeit ihr noch bleibt.
Gestern hatte Eléonore frei, aber
heute geht sie wieder zur Arbeit.
Und ab heute begleitet sie
ihr kleiner Corgi Ostralie.
Viens, mon petit chien!
Für den ersten Auftritt
bei ihren Kolleginnen
nimmt sie den Welpen aus der Box,
damit sie
auch gebührend empfangen wird.
Süss!
Und was für ein Empfang!
Ostralie hat alle Herzen erobert.
Wer bist denn du?
Süss, so klein!
Die Nacht war nicht immer einfach.
Sie hat immer wieder gewinselt.
So herzig!
- Hm.
Komm, Ostralie!
Du weisst nicht so recht,
wo du bist. Macht nichts.
Du lebst dich schon noch ein.
Wenn sie nervt, legt sie in die Box.
Sie muss es lernen,
sonst geht es zu Hause auch nicht.
Gehen wir zum Chef?
Oh, ein kleiner Albtraum!
(Alle) Nein!
Hoi, kleines Mäuschen!
* Alle lachen. *
Willst du eine kleine Tour machen?
- Diese Öhrchen!
Ostralie kundschaftet alles aus.
Aber jetzt muss sich Eléonore
um ihre Patienten kümmern.
Iii, hui!
Oh!
Nein, er hat keine Lust.
Und nächste Woche:
Alte Liebe rostet nicht.
Eléonore ist wieder einmal
bei ihren Kühen
und hilft Sania,
ihr Kälbchen auf die Welt zu bringen.
Wir halten sie an den Läufen,
dann rollen wir sie auf die Seite.
Gute Einfälle muss man haben.
In Corcelle-près-Payerne
muss Florence den Hund Laica nähen.
Sie wurde
vom Nachbarshund angefallen.
Was macht man,
wenn ein fremder Hund angreift?
Der Besitzer ist schockiert. Er weiss
nicht, ob er Anzeige machen soll.
Im Tierspital Bern wird Loxias
notfallmässig eingeliefert.
Seine Besitzer sitzen im Ausland
auf dem Flughafen fest.
Ich gebe dir die Tierärztin.
Es ist schlimmer als wir dachten.
Alix kann nicht warten,
bis die Besitzer zurück sind.
Sie muss Loxias das Leben retten.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2020